For the next part of the exercise, we are going to add some locking functionality to our door blueprint.
To do this within the BP door blueprint, we're going to want to control the colour of the point light.
So we're going to want it to be red when the light is locked, and we're going to want it to be green when it is unlocked.
Now to do this, I'm going to create my own function.
And this function we're going to use, all it's going to do is update the light.
So I'm going to come over into the function section here, and I'm going to push plus.
That's going to give me a new function section.
And now I'm going to type in update light.
Now, in this update light, I'm going to check to see if the door is locked or unlocked.
And I'm going to switch the light accordingly.
Now, in order for us to save the state of the door, we're going to need a variable.
So I'm going to hit variable. I'm going to call this is locked. Question.
And now this is a boolean variable, so it is either true or false.
I'm going to drag this in, and I'm going to get is locked.
And then I'm going to drag off of the boolean and type in branch.
All it's going to do if this is locked, it's going to do one thing.
And if it is not locked, it's going to do something else.
Now we're going to want to update the point light.
So I'm going to drag the point light in to get a reference.
You now see we have a point light.
And from that point light, I'm going to do set color.
And that's going to give us the ability to set the light color.
Now I'm going to plug this into true to start with.
And under the new light color, I am going to select.
So this is true for if it is locked.
So if it is locked, I'm going to make it all right.
I'm going to click OK.
Now I'm going to copy this whole section, make a duplicate here.
And I will change the color to green.
Just drag that down.
And we have a green light.
So this is a simple function.
What it will do is it will update the light.
It's just going to check the variable is locked.
And if it's true, it will set it to red.
And if it's false, it's going to set it to green.
Now, I want to do something special with the is locked variable.
If we look down in the bottom left-hand corner,
there is a little eye that can be clicked on.
And that will open up the eye.
Now, this will also be referenced to the tick box
in the details panel for instance editable.
And instance editable means that we can manually change this
on each instance that we add into the world.
Now, I'll demonstrate that in a second.
The first thing is we've created a function,
but we haven't told the system to run it at all.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to come into the construction script here.
And I am going to drag off from the construction script.
And I'm going to type in update light.
So that's going to call this on construction script.
Now, there's one more thing that I want to do.
And that is I'm going to jump back to the event graph.
And now I'm going to get rid of my print string.
And I'm going to add a similar branching again.
So I will add a branch in.
And I will drag the is locked variable
and place it down there.
Now, we only want the door to open and close
if it is not locked. So is locked is false.
We will go to the flip-flop.
If it's true, it's going to do nothing.
Okay, so we've done a few things there.
We've created a new function which will update lights called update lights.
And we have connected that to the construction script.
And then on the event graph, we have added a branch in
that will allow us to stop the functionality
if the variable is set to false.
So let's compile this jump into the world.
Now, if I was to come in and create a second version of the door,
I'm going to drag this out holding down alt.
And I will move that so it's next door to it.
I'm going to delete the gun. We do not need it for this.
Now, you'll see when I have one instance of this selected,
I have an option for is locked in the details panel.
Now, if I click that on, you can see that the light turns red.
And that's because in the construction script,
it's triggered the update light function and the light is changed.
And now if I run the game, if I walk up to this door and press E,
it will do nothing. However, this door will open and close.
It's very straightforward, but we are just able to update
and control the functionality on different instances of the same blueprint.
Great. So we have now added in a locking functionality to our doors.
And we've done that by using the construction script
and creating a function that we can reuse called the update light.
Now, in the next video, what we're going to do
is we're going to create another actor with a button
which can unlock or lock the doors.